Speaker 1: This is really amazing. This will
really be, as far as I know, this is really
the final CPAC segment for the week. OK, so just
bear that in mind. We covered CPAC, we covered the
speeches. We covered Trump's lie riddled speech
from Sunday already. I'm not doing that again.
It was brought to my attention that on Fox
News, as soon as Donald Trump started telling
his election lies during his speech, Fox put
up a disclaimer clearly meant to avoid another
potential lawsuit over Donald Trump's obviously
demonstrably false claims about who won the
twenty twenty election. The disclaimer that popped
up on the screen on Fox News when Trump started
lying about who won said, quote, The voting system
companies have denied the various allegations made
by President Trump and his counsel regarding the
twenty twenty election. Let's look at and listen
to a video. If you're not watching, as soon as
Trump starts telling the lies, the disclaimer
pops up on the screen on election night.
Speaker 5: We did so much better than they
ever thought in their wildest imagination that
they just said the hell with it, let it go,
what they did, what they did. I'm also leading
in the polls against Harris because not a lot of
people think that Joe's going to be running.
But another no, this it's a strange world
and everyone else is going to run on the radical
left, whether it's on the Democrat side or the
I love my Republicans, but we're really
kick in their ass, too. But we love them,
but we like it because they're friends of
ours. Right. So it's OK. I think we can say
that affectionately now. They're great.
They're great, and they're working hard.
Speaker 1: That is really something else. But it's
also relevant that the disclaimer is pathetically
weak. The voting system companies have denied the
allegations of Trump about the election. It's not
just the voting system. Companies have denied it.
There is no evidence for it. 60 lawsuits have been
thrown out. There have been audits and audits
and so-called audits and hearings and hearings.
And there should be a statement that says there
is no evidence whatsoever of election fraud that
would impact the results and even a single state.
So on the one hand, it's notable that Fox News,
now that they are under lawsuit from Dominion and
we'll get to that in a second. They're putting
up this disclaimer as soon as Trump starts lying.
But then the other part of this, the other side of
this is the disclaimer is pathetically weak. It's
a disclaimer that basically puts Trump's claims
of fraud and Dominion's denials of fraud on the
same footing. Right. It's OK. So Trump is claiming
fraud and Dominion voting systems has denied the
fraud. It's kind of like a both sides think FOX
News is saying that we're telling you what each
side is saying and that's it. But if you do news,
you should be able to say there is absolutely no
evidence of what Donald Trump is claiming here.
It's not just Trump claims and Dominion denies.
And in fact, it's not just fear of lawsuits that's
at play. Fox News is being sued. Fox News is being
sued by Dominion voting systems. And not only
that, not only that, in this very same lawsuit
just a few days ago, Dominion Voting Systems
has subpoenaed Rudy Giuliani, Cydney Powell and my
pillow CEO Michael Andell in that very lawsuit. So
this is very actively very real, but it's still
a really weak disclaimer. If Fox News had guts
or any concern for journalistic integrity, they
would say the election was won fairly by President
Biden. Contrary to Donald Trump's claims, the
election was won fairly by Joe Biden. There is
no evidence at all that supports Donald Trump's
claims. Instead, they do this pathetic, flaccid,
weak disclaimer. But the fact that they're doing
it at all, we know why. It's because of what's
going on legally at this point in time. We're
following the lawsuit. There's been no real news
on it recently. They've sent these subpoenas to
Rudy Sidney Powell and Mike Lendell. We don't know
what's actually going to happen as far as their
involvement in the suit goes, but we will keep you
posted about it. But Fox News doing the absolute
minimum. It's sort of like a back page. Retraction
that nobody sees, but the newspaper hopes clears
them legally. That's what Fox News is doing here.